good morning John you may have heard
they were in the middle of something of
an environmental crisis climate change
oil spills dead zones garbage patches
meltdowns mass extinction the root of
all these problems is people us you and
me and Jacques Chirac and everybody
watching this video and everybody they
know and everybody who's ever made a
movie with Kevin Bacon the environmental
crisis that we currently inhabit was
created to satisfy the needs or at least
the whims of humans so the question
becomes given the marvelous beauty and
tremendous value of these biological
systems that as far as we know are
unique in the universe are we worth it
would the world be better off without us
is humanity and our culture our
civilization or technology just an
asteroid bearing down on the planet
destroying everything in its path
basically should I feel bad for existing
is what I'm asking my suspicion is that
most people don't spend a lot of time
worrying about this but I do and I've
come to the conclusion after years of
thinking about this that were worth it I
might be biased towards humans being one
of them and all but in the same way that
the complexity of the natural world is
beautiful and marvelous and as far as we
know unique so is the technological
world in the psychological world in the
sociological world there's something
really marvelous about humanity that is
really easy not to notice when you're
inside of it all the time I've heard
people say yeah sure Humanity is the
smartest but cheetahs are the fastest
and blue whales are the biggest and
barnacles are the longest penises it's
all completely subjective it's about
what trait you choose to put value on
but I don't buy that I think those
people probably know that there is
something different something special
about people the scale on which our
brains have allowed us to create
everything from tiny little ideas to the
Burj Kalifa we create we've created
cultures an atomic theory and Bridget
Jones's Diary and Star Trek and
honky-tonk music all of these tiny units
of seemingly ceaseless complexity in
order it's extremely valuable and unique
we are not an asteroid even if in the
end and I hope we don't we have the same
effect on the biodiversity of the planet
witnessing the scale of humanity's
achievement in our creation and the
interaction of that with the natural
world and the way that it allows us to
understand the natural world that's the
closest I get to spiritual it fills me
with awe and joy and Wonder and pride
yeah we have done things for which I
will never forgive us but we create more
than we destroy that's got to be the
goal to destroy less and to create more
to increase awesome and decrease suck
that's that's what I believe in that is
what I believe in that I think humans
ultimately are pretty good at and are
getting better at John I'll see you on
Tuesday endscreen
few things going on one crash course
psychology starring me is just launched
on youtube.com slash crash course if you
want to check it out
we are going to be using our minds to
explore online too I promise this time
I'm coming back to hand games cuz it's
been John games for a long time multiple
videos per week including Pikmin 3 and
Hank and Katherine play Super Mario
Brothers you three if you haven't heard
already dftba records our merch company
needs a bigger warehouse so we're
leaving our old warehouse and moving to
a new one and we would rather not take
all of our old shirts with us so we're
selling them for $10 a piece which is
about half of what they usually cost
about two months old out but there are
many more that are not sold out there's
a link in the description to all the
things that are on sale or just go to
dftba.com and holding back this is the
time ok thanks for listening to me
rationalize why humans should exist ok
that's it for real this time